[Música]
fin del título 42 en Estados Unidos y
entrada en vigor del título 8 las normas
migratorias previas a la pandemia que
incluyen también un mecanismo de
deportación el gobierno estadounidense
advirtió que la frontera no está abierta
y que aquellos que la crucen de manera
irregular serán deportados
aumenta la desnutrición infantil en
Haití y una de las responsables de ellos
la violencia de las pandillas unicef
reveló un informe en el que explica que
este flagelo reportó un 30% más de casos
respecto al conteo anterior tenemos las
opiniones de este organismo
la frontera entre Colombia y Venezuela
verá aumentada la cantidad de oficiales
instaurados en sus pasos fronterizos
este acuerdo es parte de los resultados
de la reunión de los ministros de
defensa de ambos países en Caracas
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos este
Informativo en la frontera entre Estados
Unidos y México en donde se registró un
nuevo récord de detenciones en las
últimas horas esto debido a la afluencia
masiva de migrantes por el fin del
título 42 quedará paso al título 8 así
se conoce la norma migratoria previa a
la pandemia que permite la petición de
asilo dentro de territorio
estadounidense pero también incluye un
mecanismo de deportación el gobierno
estadounidense modificó la normativa
para que sea más difícil ser elegible
para el asilo y advertido que Quienes no
hayan solicitado protección en un tercer
país no serán admitidos en la Unión
Americana anteriormente hablamos con
Yuli Rodríguez defensora de derechos
humanos y miembro del Consejo ciudadano
del Instituto Nacional de Migración en
México quien nos contestaba si los
migrantes temen quedarse en un limbo
fronterizo
entre las dos
fronteras este pensar que están una vez
que dentro en la detención este pensar
que con la entrevista Ya ellos pueden
Ingresar a Estados Unidos y la realidad
es otra totalmente distinta porque ya vi
un acuerdo entre el gobierno de México y
Estados Unidos de manera clara que
México va a recibir 30.000 personas por
mes es decir mil por días por cada día
entonces lo que se espera es una
deportación masiva mensual ahí ahí este
una situación muy complicada para las
personas que están ingresando o que
piensan ingresar esta madrugada a
Estados Unidos de manera irregular Se le
pide a la gente pues que no lo haga en
previsión de esta expiración del título
42 la cámara de representantes de
mayoría republicana aprobó un proyecto
de ley destinado a la detención de
personas migrantes irregulares la norma
conocida como la hr2 que los demócratas
ya han dicho que vetarán en el senado
buscaría limitar aún más el número de
solicitantes de asilo así como a pedirlo
fuera del país y seguir con la
construcción de un muro en la frontera
al aprobar hr2 los republicanos de la
cámara han demostrado que estamos
enfocados en abordar los mayores
desafíos de nuestra nación por el
contrario la Casa Blanca tuvo dos años
para planificar el fin del título 42
todos conocíamos la fecha límite pero la
Casa Blanca no hizo ningún plan no
cumplió con la fecha límite y se metió
en otra crisis
seguimos en Estados Unidos porque el
expresidente de ese país Donald Trump
apeló El veredicto que lo responsabilizó
de abusar sexualmente y de difamar a la
escritora y Jean Carroll además lo
obligó a pagarle a ella 5 millones de
dólares el republicano no sólo da la
pelea en las Cortes el miércoles durante
un programa televisivo Trump se refirió
de manera despectiva a carrollándola de
loca la escritora estaría considerando
presentar una nueva demanda en contra
del Magnate por lo que podría ser un
nuevo caso de difamación
y la violencia en Haití contribuyó a que
se disparara la desnutrición infantil en
ese país el más reciente reporte de
unicef muestra que los casos aumentaron
un 30% respecto a 2022 a las causas se
suma la propagación del cólera y la
inseguridad alimentaria anteriormente
hablamos con Logan dubilié Vocero de
unicef para América Latina y del Caribe
quien nos contaba cómo los
enfrentamientos en las calles impiden
que los niños tengan acceso no solo
alimentos sino también a servicios de
higiene y saneamiento lo que vemos como
situación en el terreno en las calles de
Puerto Príncipe pero también en el resto
del país es un aumento de la violencia
de calle de la guerra entre las
pandillas lo que impide que las mamás
los papás puedan llevar a sus hijos a
sus hijas en los centros de salud no
pueden seguir a comprar aumentos no
pueden ir a buscar agua potable y esos
elementos esos ingredientes desde hace
meses y meses ahora conllevan una
situación de deterioro de la situación
humanitaria y en aumento significativo
de las desnutrición aguda grave de estos
niños estamos hablando de un aumento de
30% es enorme en menos de un año y son
niños desnutridos que viven en una
situación de supervivencia su vida está
en riesgo su vida está en peligro si no
reciben medidas humanitarias directas si
no reciben asistencia humanitaria
directa entre tanto Nicaragua el
gobierno sandinista de Daniel Ortega A
través de la Corte Suprema de Justicia
despojó a más abogados de todos sus
títulos así lo anunció el propio máximo
tribunal a través de un comunicado en el
que se especifica el nombre de 25
abogados y notarios públicos
todos ellos parte de los 222 expresos
que Ortega desterró a Estados Unidos en
febrero esto tan solo dos días después
de que se le quitaron sus títulos a la
también abogada y defensora de derechos
de disidentes políticos Leonard y
Martinez
y Colombia y Venezuela acordaron
aumentar la cantidad de oficiales en los
pasos fronterizos informales ese es uno
de los resultados de la reunión de los
ministros de defensa de ambos países
quienes dialogaron en Caracas además
Venezuela entregará tres embarcaciones
colombianas que estaban retenidas desde
2020 Ramiro cuevar berena no se amplía
Colombia Venezuela continúan estrechando
sus lazos luego de que este jueves en
Caracas los ministros de defensa de
ambos países acordaran Un aumento de las
tropas en los pasos informales de la
frontera El objetivo combatir a los
grupos criminales que operan a lo largo
de los 2.200 kilómetros compartidos sin
especificar plazos ni la cantidad de
unidades ambos resaltaron la decisión de
combatir estas organizaciones
le transmitía al Señor ministro padrino
este propósito que es una decisión del
presidente Gustavo Petro
de enfrentar las finanzas criminales
con la mayor contundencia posible como
lo venimos haciendo en Colombia y se
viene haciendo en Venezuela también
confirmaron que Caracas devolverá tres
embarcaciones retenidas de 2020 tras ser
encontradas a la deriva y sin
tripulación en una Ribera del río
Orinoco un gesto que para los ministros
resalta las mejoras en las relaciones
bilaterales pero hablando en privado
estábamos admirados de lo rápido que
hemos avanzado y de cómo hemos sanado
aquellas heridas para avanzar para
construir nuestro futuro nuestro nuestro
bienestar colectivo nacional desde la
Asunción de Gustavo Petro como
presidente colombiano las relaciones con
Venezuela se han reactivado incluyendo
la reapertura de fronteras terrestres y
el patrocinio de reuniones para
solucionar la crisis política venezolana
nos vamos hasta Perú en donde hoy habló
el expresidente Pedro Castillo quien se
pronunció sobre su situación tras ser
detenido el pasado diciembre de 2022
esto luego del fallido autogolpe tras
decretar el cierre del Congreso Castillo
aseguró este jueves ser un preso
político que no cometió ningún acto de
rebelión ni menos de Conspiración porque
no se levantó en armas acusó además al
congreso y a la prensa de no haber
aceptado nunca su Victoria
yo no me levanté en armas el día que yo
Leo ese mensaje esa proclama ni siquiera
tenía un cortador
no coordiné con nadie no llamé a nadie
específicamente para para que se
levanten armas por eso es que necesito
saber cuál es la imputación específica
que se me hace el Ministerio Público la
señora
que representa el día de hoy al
ministerio público acaba de manifestar
que la lectura de mi mensaje se debe a
los actos de corrupción previo No yo no
soy corrupto yo no lo robé a nadie
cerramos con la última noticia que dio
El Magnate y LoL más que en relación a
la red social Twitter más que anunció
que en el plazo de seis semanas dejará
de ser el ceo de la red social y una
mujer de la que no ha dado más
información lo reemplazará el
multimillonario propietario también de
la empresa de cohetes spacex ya había
anunciado el pasado noviembre quedaría
Este paso con el que pasará a ser
solamente director ejecutivo
emocionado denunciar que he contratado a
un nuevo para Twitter comenzará en seis
semanas mi rol pasará a ser presidente
ejecutivo y seteó supervisando productos
software y cyzops así cerramos este
informativo sigan conectados a France 24
y France 24.com
[Música]